so many people are would say would look
at you or encounter you and say oh my
god there's someone who I've known all
my life who's been on television in
movies and they would get starstruck
have you ever gets music people music
people I met Bruce Springsteen and I
kissed his wife Patti I kissed your hand
yeah and then I kissed his hand and then
I excused myself yeah I met Elton John I
said John I have excuse me I left the
room yeah his his name isn't John right
ergo I left the room it's Bob yeah I met
SIA yeah she came up to me cuz I I tweet
about her yeah I love SIA
yeah and she said I'm seeing but I don't
know because I've only seen over the wig
yeah I have no idea what she looked like
anyone can say I see yeah yeah and they
do yeah she's a different height yeah
when you met so you member would you
meet her I met her at in a grocery store
yeah and I gave her a hug she um she
took a picture with me but I never put
it online because I thought I'm going to
respect that she has a secret identity
and we never Spector right like if you
meet Batman when he's Bruce Wayne you
just stay chill up have you I've met
yeah I made the mistake of meeting Bruce
Wayne at the supermarket and been like
Batman
and then I tweeted a photo and he got
mad get really mad